Casey Bloys: Based on George R.R. Martin's
book Fire & Blood.
This new show takes place 300 years before
Game of Thrones.
It tells the story of House Targaryen in the
earlier days of Westeros.
I don't want to give away too much but what
I will tell you is that House of the Dragon
is co-created
and executive produced by George and Ryan
Condal and also executive produced
and directed by Miguel Sapochnik.
Miguel, of course, is one of the most masterful
Game of Thrones directors.
He won an Emmy for the unforgettable episode
Battle of the Bastards.
We couldn't be happier to have found the next
great chapter in George's saga
and we wanted this news to bring our content
presentation to a close.
Thank you all very much for your time today.